So what's so special about Gulp?
I teased it a little already,
but let's have a closer look.
The main difference between Grunt and
Gulp is that Grunt focuses on
configuration, while
Gulp focuses on code.
But what does that
even mean in practice?
Have a look at this Grunt
configuration file.
It's not important that you understand
everything it does right away.
We'll get to that later.
It uses a JavaScript config object,
to configure certain tasks,
such as concat or uglify.
To change or
extend one of these tasks, you would
have to modify the plugins themselves.
Consider the same functionality
in this gulp config file instead.
It looks more like son of JavaScript,
and that's a good thing.
At any given point,
you can intervene, and type your files
into another function before moving on.
The second big argument
is all about speed.
Grunt executes tasks in sequence.
One after each other.
Where Gulp, by default,
executes tasks in parallel, and
finishes when all have finished.
But that's not all that makes
Gulp usually come up much faster.
Gulp comes with the concept of streams,
that cause much less IO, or
file system access.
And James will tell you a bit more
about how streams work in just a bit.
Head to the Gulp installation
instructions and instructor notes,
and install Gulp on your system.
If you haven't done so already,
you need to install Node.js and
NPM before that, and
those instructions are also in the note.
If you need a little more
help figuring it out,
the next note will have
more detailed instructions.